hey guys how's it going today's [ __ ]
show is brought to you by Square cash
square cash is an absolute you know what
it's the best way to pay people for
things anything send money it's totally
free and fast and the most payments that
you have on this if you the most
payments that you do can be deposited
directly into your bank account in
seconds so download the free square cash
app for iPhone or Android now now if you
don't have an iPhone or Android change
it what up everybody you know what how
is how are you this is congratulations
episode I don't know I don't know I
never know what episode it is that's
kind of the beauty of it I just kind of
get in there and I [ __ ] kakakaka kick
ack ack ack ack ack ack ack ack ack ack
ack ack ack ack ack you know not
thinking about numbers thinking about
you guys alright
definitely not thinking about you guys
I'm just kind of talking um so here I am
I'm still in Toronto I'm doing this
movie and I am I am it's it's pouring
it's [ __ ] pouring out I got one
hoodie and a jacket and I got to wear
both of them if it's even if it is
called but if it wasn't cold I'd still
have to [ __ ] wear both of the things
because it helps the rain and not touch
my face in hair and you know I'm not a
diva or anything it's just annoying when
that happens to have [ __ ] things
hitting your face even if it's water um
don't ever have things hit in your face
never want things hit in my face dude
one time I was uh before we get into it
one time I was in high school I think I
was already graduated in my one of my
brother's friends it was like a big guy
and his thing was that he was the big
guy and people were like horsing around
at this like party in high school and
this guy like touched his face as a joke
and any
he got real serious and he was like hey
man don't touch my face man I have a
thing I have a thing where like don't
people don't don't touch my face and I
remember even then I must have been 19
thinking this guy's full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what do you mean that's a thing
you know I'm talking about
that's just your face this is my hand if
I touch it I touch it
what do you mean it's a thing you got
[ __ ] like he didn't it wasn't a crazy
person didn't have you know wasn't an
insane lunatic it was just a big guy I
don't like when people like have things
and try to develop the things because
and then they hide they hide behind
those things because they think that's
their identity not I mean to get all dr.
Phil on your ass but you don't really
have things we're just beings on a
planet okay we're [ __ ] animals on a
planet so you don't have a thing you
touch my face maybe I don't like it but
it's not a thing you just touched my
face and don't touch it so things are
hitting my face cuz it's raining all the
time sounds like a [ __ ] Garth Brooks
song slick step rostov things hit my
face all the time
not like that well I actually don't like
that cuz I have a thing about hit my
face don't hit my face um so yeah I'm
here still in Toronto doing the movie
I'm one of the supporting roles uh it's
a bigger role it's probably like the
fourth there's some stars and then me
some [ __ ] Joker boy but uh so I'm not
in its the movies basically about two
people and it's them uh in it and then
everyone else is like in it sometimes so
I got a lot of downtime which means
boredom and I said I was bored last
night on snapchat or something in
Toronto and people were like dude you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] Toronto is not boring
now I wasn't saying Toronto's boring I
was saying I was [ __ ] being boring
and I was just being you know but um
yeah whatever I was still chilling
though man
I was still [ __ ] happy just laying
around with just a shirt on in my hotel
bed that's some boss [ __ ] you understand
laying around in a hotel bed with just
your shirt on who the [ __ ] am i Don
Draper huh um see ya uh I went on I had
about 3,000 [ __ ] Facebook requests and
I went through all of them I don't know
why that's how bored I was um
oh and saw the ten bands thing that
people have been doing on Facebook Oh
ten here ten bands I've seen one of them
is a lie which one's a lie and then
literally they will go around ten bands
I've seen and they'll be like blink 182
RZA [ __ ] Garth Brooks puddle of mud
Smash Mouth Incubus Papoose Third Eye
Blind Soundgarden Dishwalla
literally can't think of another band
but then they'll be like Oh which one's
a lie and then the friends are like
[ __ ] dude there's no way you went to
go see Soundgarden that's the lie or
whiz it Rizza doesn't make sense with
that or Papoose you didn't go see
Pappy's and then I guess they tell them
at the end that's uh if you're the kind
of person that that puts out you got it
I don't know man I guess you're either a
bored ass housewife or a guy with no job
or a [ __ ] complete narcissist dude if
imagine going up to somebody in in the
world and being like that you kind of
know like an acquaintance because that's
what Facebook is and being like hey man
hey dude well what's up dude I haven't
seen you in a while I'll man it cool to
see you again dude I'm gonna name I'm
gonna rattle off ten [ __ ] concerts
I've been to you guess which one's a lie
that other person should be like this ah
go [ __ ] yourself I'll just do my day
that's insane that somebody would care
about that or give a [ __ ] ten concerts
one's a lie PS M an idiot don't [ __ ]
post dumbass [ __ ] hey you alright fellas
here we go it's been going around just
put the first the last picture you took
in your camera roll posted here [ __ ]
no cheating or or or put up a pic of me
you and me if you have a picture you and
me put it up don't even care if I look
like the [ __ ] guy with the bent ear
from the Goonies do it see what and then
do it then repost it to come pictures
you get yeah dude I don't think that's
the slick stuff that Garth Brooks was
talking about when he was on Facebook
don't think
was um by the way News News News News
[ __ ] jean-claude van damme has a
Twitter dude
John do you understand what I'm saying
jean-claude van damme has a Twitter
that's good okay
love John Claude Van Damme and let's see
he posted a video and people were
sending it to me because because this is
the video he sent and put it on hi
friends welcome to my official Twitter
account and there's a video of him on a
rock with a hat on in sunglasses the
rock is overseeing the ocean that's it
that's it it's two seconds that's what
he says twitter twitter I mean is there
anything funnier Twitter I'm going to
get on this rock son of a [ __ ] I'm
going to sit down I you know what I like
to think that John Claude Van Damme woke
up one morning and was like yeah by the
way maybe oh no no I thought for at
first it would be the best if he lived
right at that Beach and that's where his
house was like right overlooking the
ocean because obviously he's got a lot
of money my favorite though is if he
lives in the city and he wakes up and he
wakes up and he's like do you know what
today is the day where I am getting a
Twitter son of a [ __ ] get in the Audi
and I'm going to go - do you know what
we do we go to the beach we go to the
beach and we drive all the way out there
I have a spot where I do meditation and
I get on the rock and I look out of into
the best ocean and that is when you feel
me saying Twitter and that is my first
win that is to me if that's his day then
that's the best thing for me for me
selfishly
think of jean-claude van damme doing
that and driving from the city to the
rock that he goes to meditate on to be
like Twitter and and and then he
probably shot it a few times like this
two second video where he was just like
where he's checked it we did it once and
then he's like [ __ ] as assistant or is
like a life or like one of the side guys
he [ __ ] for sure and not even in a gay
way you know he [ __ ] dudes but like in
alike you know not he's not gay but he's
just like you have to you have to [ __ ]
guys and you and his other friends will
be like why and he'd be like because it
is a wonderful thing to experience all
of the things in life and then you're
there like but jungler that's gay and he
says it is not gay don't say that it is
powerful and also an experience and he
[ __ ] guys on that rock and then when he
[ __ ] bust a nut he's like Twitter so
it takes the [ __ ] thing to the rock
and he was like okay shoot me here we go
Twitter let me see and then he looks and
it was like and and then he when he when
he checks it he goes like this this is
this is what it is
no let's do it again
and then he gets on the rock and action
Twitter cut let me see that's the one
and then he goes get in the Audi and
drives all the way back to the city and
then [ __ ] a guy because of let's [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] now guy but I'm not gay
neither am i drop your pants here we go
that's the junk advantium I want to
believe in so that
I mean that's [ __ ] hilarious to me
there's only things as funny as that to
me if that really happened then oh by
the way guess if Jean Claude Van Damme
was in a [ __ ] wife beater or not when
you shot that video he was cuz he's John
Claude Van Damme as Jung ko Van Damme
ever not wearing a wife-beater even when
he has to dress up in a suit he's
definitely got a white Peter under it
there's no way there is no way he either
has a wife beater on always or no shirt
period there is no way jean-claude Van
Damme has ever in his life not had a
wife beater on like one time like they
were like his publicist was like we
gotta wear a tux I brought it he was
like where's my wife beat her [ __ ] and
she was like oh I don't know you and he
cuz I guess you're fired and she says oh
my gosh but I've been working with you
for years and he says then you know I
always wear wife-beater under anything
one time I went scuba diving and I was
wearing white bitter under it
see you on Twitter so that's for sure
what it was that's how I like to imagine
him um that's enough talking about
jean-claude van damme also it's it I
kind of feel like I mean I know it's
jean-claude but if you're in America
mostly say jean-claude or you could do
like a marrying of the two Jean Jean
Jean Claude but if you're a [ __ ]
straight-up American and you're like all
of a sudden talking and then you're like
well yeah jean-claude Van Damme he piece
of [ __ ] so what char um alright dude
look everybody's been tweeting me about
this and I find it a compliment because
I like to know that you guys know that
you guys um want to know my thoughts on
this and I talked about it on Twitter on
Twitter
you guys and I know you wanted it you
did it and I know you did it but and
here's the thing I talked about it on
mmm a bit but this truck fire festival I
keep wanting to say fry because of the
way it looks cuz they spelled it with a
[ __ ] why to be cool which is so
stupid
alright um I don't know what by the way
I don't know what Coachella means but at
least make it stagecoach
I know it's a word or whatever but like
they kept it real stagecoach that didn't
[ __ ] hip-hop it up your [ __ ] dorks
Coachella is its own thing I know what
that means it sounds like a word that's
made up and they made it up cool spell
it however you want to but fire festival
there's your dead giveaway you spelled
it with a why alright look there's so
many dead giveaways I don't know if you
know about the fire festival if you know
what happened or not but it was this
thing that blew up [ __ ] all over the
other day and Instagram and dude I mean
it's this festival that was created in
the past few months I don't know how to
describe this but you know you know you
know what it is just google it alright
google it or just go on [ __ ] and look
hashtag the fire festival spell up with
a why but dude I mean it's this festival
that was in the Bahamas that they [ __ ]
said was going to be amazing and it
wasn't and these idiots because they
basically paid these social media stars
like thousands of dollars to promote it
on their instagrams and maybe I don't
know but so they're there's these
influencers they gave these influencers
influencers money to post about aiming
kendall Jenner did it by the way kendall
Jenner rough month man with the [ __ ]
Pepsi and then also the [ __ ] fire
festival this thing went down inch in
[ __ ] shambles it was ja rule by the
way I read about it and ja Rule said
something like there was a toast when
when the fire festival was starting
would know not when it was starting but
when they decided to have to get it
going like they were like unsure if it
was
work out and they decided was going to
work out and they were going to prep it
shahrullah said something like let us
eat like kings and live like [ __ ]
whatever and [ __ ] like porn stars or
whatever it it you 45 don't say [ __ ]
like that k but dude so anyway these
people spent from $500 to $12,000 to go
on this island and dude and and they
were promised like swimming pigs and
like blink-182 and ja Rule hey dude I
will literally and nothing against these
guys some of these guys music I even
like but I would literally pay five
grand to get out of doing that and I'm
not joking to to go if somebody said to
me hey do you want to go to the Bahamas
and listen and watch a and watch a and
and to watch blink 182 and ja Rule and
be with a bunch of swimming pigs because
that's on the itinerary I would say how
much do I have to pay to get out of
doing that and I'm not being funny right
now I know this is a comedy podcast but
you don't understand
dude when they said was going to be like
a culinary experience
they served them bread with [ __ ]
cheese and wilted lettuce people were
trapped there because there were too
many people on the Bahamas or some on
this island and the [ __ ] Bahamas was
like we got to keep them in the airport
they locked them in dude who the [ __ ]
cares about a festival pays thousands of
dollars to go when the festival's never
been done before and ja Rule and
blink-182 are the headliners and you're
going to be with pigs you're gonna be
with pigs dude I love how somebody was
like marketing genius dude talk about
Don Draper oh but there's pigs on this
island they're never gonna want to come
cuz pigs hey who the [ __ ] wants to be
around a pig
got a question for you you farmer hey
hey you farmer in that farmer your
person your regular person with a day
job and that day job doesn't consist of
you being a farmer so what a [ __ ] if
somebody goes to me hey hold this pig I
go like this now find someone else to
hold it I'm going to go over in the
direction where the pig isn't but I love
how they flipped it on their ass and
they were like just tell them the
[ __ ] pigs are still get to be with
swimming pigs like that's a thing
swimming pigs dude if you put any animal
in a [ __ ] body of water they're
swimming it doesn't mean it's a [ __ ]
event dude if I put my dog in the pool
if I said hey guys come over I have a
swimming dog in the Pope you'll be like
go [ __ ] yourself ah right I mean if your
dogs cute cool but dude what dude [ __ ]
this fire festival and then djaro people
dragged ja Rule on it if you went dude
you need stimulation that's the thing
man I know I was talking about it on the
other [ __ ] podcast but dude just be
you don't have to jump on every [ __ ]
I know somebody that went to [ __ ] in
both weeks at Coachella and one and and
also stagecoach how sad are you if
you've done that how much stimulation
can't you just be happy just being know
cuz you kuda he kuda you see something
you go oh is that God go yo kuda you're
a bear a [ __ ] kuda man that sees a
shiny ass bracelet on a boat
I mean dude they paid these [ __ ] and
this thing was promoted through
influencers you know what an influencer
is this is another here's another word
for an influencer yeah uh you know why
because that's not a word because an
influencer is nothing it's not a thing
you live in bond day all day [ __ ] it
bond day every day man fire festival was
bond date to the nth degree man nah nah
I loved seeing those pictures of those
[ __ ] disaster relief tents there were
like luxury accommodations and they put
up [ __ ] white tents like they were in
a [ __ ] suicide uh cult like they were
all gonna drink some [ __ ] poison
kool-aid dude if you went to fire
festival straight up you [ __ ] idiot
you are you don't need all the info
that's hilarious
you know what you are you believe in
fake news that's what that was fake
[ __ ] news there come on we got ja
Rule we got blink-182 it's gonna cost
you thousands of dollars culinary
experience
say no more fam shrooming pigs i said
say no more but [ __ ] it where's the jet
swimming pigs oh man they flipped that
on their ass dude it's like it's like
it's like marketing 101 I mean I don't
know [ __ ] about marketing but it's like
oh yeah but nobody I don't to go to that
city it's dangerous yeah yeah yeah so
let's promote it like this hey let's go
to the city you never know what could
happen oh really
sounds mysterious and you go there
[ __ ] stabbed shot robbed
oh this somebody should have told me we
did you [ __ ] idiot you bought into
marketing
you [ __ ] lemming you lemming you coud
dude your life's a [ __ ] master
if you make it that way don't [ __ ] go
to some Island my god
I mean every show every TV show they've
made about about an island it's all been
a disaster
Lost Gilligan's Island all other ones
too probably I don't know for sure
unbelievable yeah but that was my
favorite thing of 2017 the [ __ ] what
do you call it a fire festival they even
were lazy with an entire festival like
all this [ __ ] Burning Man all this [ __ ]
like that go by um so I don't know man
I I got a I got a UH what do you call it
um - no I said I talk about I got to
[ __ ] I get a voicemail from my I got
two voicemails one from a [ __ ] friend
and the other one from a friend that I
haven't talked about talked to in a
while and I don't check the voice do you
check voicemails I mean I know a lot of
people check voicemails but there's text
messaging like hooli like honestly
unless you're a [ __ ] dad with a kid
over [ __ ] 16 or a mom who's checking
voicemails uh it's weird who's leaving
them I don't I don't check them dude
people leave me voicemails I don't check
them I haven't talked to them they're
like hey man I left your voicemail nah
did you check did you text me like a
[ __ ] person or you Luddite yo are you
Amish oh you left a voicemail oh that's
cool man where'd you get a phone though
to do that because you're Yama SH in
Pennsylvania in Virginia oh you're still
in LA oh oh you're in the met
metropolitan city oh okay but how's that
how's it happening since you're in a
small town in Pennsylvania I'm an idiot
I don't even know if that's or [ __ ]
uh Amish people are props to the Amish
though keeping it really real you know
keeping it really [ __ ] real people
like [ __ ] that they're like oh your
technology is gonna be changing that
much now I'll just [ __ ] keep these
clothes on and chill near hey that's
cool you keep connected with everybody
in the world at the touch of your
fingertips instead of that I'm going to
be with my family and some
animals and wear this hat um I was
listening to a podcast on TED talk and
they were talking about technology and
how its expanding and how its expanding
exponentially right like the the
PlayStation they were saying it was on
TED talk he was on Ted
[ __ ] podcast TED talk I don't know
why why Ted by the way I don't like that
it's called TED talk is that the guy
that created it or is that an acronym
for something either way change it
because it's not a guy
don't make your TED that just sounds
like a boring guy oh yeah I want to
listen to a guy named TED talk you know
[ __ ] boring that is think about that
hey my buddy Ted's gonna come over and
talk that's what you think of I'm I know
that's nice not what it is the TED talk
but yeah my buddy Ted's coming over he's
gonna give a talk Oh bye oh cool I'm
gonna go [ __ ] eat cheese because it's
better but they were talking about how
technology is exponentially uh growing
and about how the PlayStation nowadays
is stronger and more powerful than a a
military-grade computer in the 60s or
whatever the [ __ ] and and about how you
know how crazy it is and how some people
are like ya know
machines are going to take over the
world and we can't do that and and how
we can't [ __ ] you know we can't have
that happen
but it's already in motion it's
definitely happening I mean there's no
way you know there already are robots
and machines that are doing jobs better
than what what the [ __ ] we do I mean you
see about the [ __ ] I was talking about
in a podcast earlier about uh they're
gonna flip burgers we're not going to
need burger flippers I think you could
it started happening you know because
all these [ __ ] people are bitching
about minimum wage is like oh you can
make cheaper to make a robots but they
were saying about how even like they
have like robots now or machines that
can
actually find I forget what kind of
cancer it is the UM something like the
cancer the blood lymph the would have
talked I don't I'm an idiot but they
were saying that uh it can detect oh no
lung cancer was lung cancer it can
detect lung cancer uh in people better
than like doctors and [ __ ] or something
some [ __ ] and it's like that can
help [ __ ] that's good so they
were saying well that's good but then
the bad [ __ ] was it's gonna be people
gonna be out of jobs but they were
saying that the best thing was that
[ __ ] when humans work along with
machines and that [ __ ] is crazy about
how like because you know we have
awareness and machines don't really have
a warrant though they don't have
awareness I guess yet but will they or
whatever are there going to be this all
this interconnectivity about [ __ ]
where robots think with each other and
that's going to become like a whole new
Internet where it's like the skin around
the world that [ __ ] can can work
together but the they were like this
[ __ ] is going to be when [ __ ] humans
work in conjunction with robots and
machines because we have like this
awareness and and [ __ ] like that and
that was crazy man like going into work
in five to ten years is just going to be
completely [ __ ] different than it is
now but all I give a [ __ ] about is what
going in and I know it already happens
and just being like light Tom and the
lights just go boom and I go TV on and
the TV goes today on the news but to me
my new people to me options rule I can
do it shower on
you know what I mean car start hmm
I'm talking about Twitter on do you know
what I mean
that's the [ __ ] I want and I know it
already happen but like that when that
becomes commonplace but they were saying
they're gonna be no more homeless people
because there's gonna be a robot you
[ __ ] helping them out I don't know
man that's gonna be a crazy world
I'm Way too dumb to [ __ ] expand on it
but that's what they were saying ah
that's crazy man but you know the like
my what I want to know is are there
gonna be robots I mean I guess there
will be one day robots that [ __ ]
legitimately look like people and then
when they get a mind of their own
they're gonna like there's going to be a
robot that rapes another human and
that's gonna be insane because also
they're not gonna give a [ __ ] if it's a
male or a female that like a lot of
dudes are gonna be getting raped by
robots that look like them you know that
imagine cuz bro I'm getting a robot that
looks like me and when that robot turns
on me and [ __ ] me there's nothing you
can do even if you have you know how you
have that I think we talked about this
maybe I don't know if I talked about
this or not maybe I checked about on
stage one day but like to be like stop
release or whatever but it's like no and
it's still [ __ ] you and you're like
no release banana or whatever you're
safe or it is oh and it doesn't give a
[ __ ] scariest moment of anyone's life uh
that that would be [ __ ] incredible
incredibly you're not I'm talking about
[ __ ] this can be happening all over the
[ __ ] world and we're [ __ ]
haha guys I want to talk to you about me
on DS me undies are designed and there's
this underwear that I use I wear I
always wear them there I wear them now
and they're designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro modal and it's
this fabric that's three times softer
than cotton and if you're not wearing
this just put it around your legs it's
amazing it's softer than anything you've
the first time I put I had to actually
adjust putting when I put it on oh man
my whole life's gonna change
and it was Chile's I just sat down for
like 25 minutes and enjoyed this
underwear on me and you can save time
and money with a monthly subscription to
this underwear so you don't have to you
know but it's cool it's got classic
colors bold shades very adventurous
patterns so you can you know tailor it
to your own personal style but also if
you're not ready for the subscription
that's okay you can still save just a go
on the website and the undies is
offering you a 20% off your first pair
just use the special URL me Indies comm
/ Congrats 20% off your first pair my
undies comm / Congrats go ahead revamp
your underwear drawer you don't think
about underwear style and that's bad
because you need to have style because
you chicks can you take your pants off
at 6 to see your bad underwear be like
never mind me undies comm / Congrats 20%
off you got to go there and you got to
get this underwear it's honestly I'm
telling you as Chris D'Elia
the best underwear square cache uh now I
got to do this
I got you got to download the square
cash app because it's the best way to
pay I know you probably got other apps
to pay for this money people with maybe
you do because there are other apps out
there what I want you to do is I want
you to grab your phone you listening to
me right now on your phone a great phone
I want to go to that app want you to
delete it I want you to delete that app
and then I want you to download the
square cash app because it's the best
way to pay people for stuff period I
told you if you're in with the MA
Afiya and union you owe money to the
[ __ ] mafia use square cash and
they'll be like huh thanks for the
recommendation I didn't know supposed to
Donilon square cash but thanks for
sending me my [ __ ] moolah my [ __ ]
chatter true a [ __ ] app that can
download kit that I can [ __ ] get it
immediately
god [ __ ] immediately you get it
immediately download the square cash app
for iOS or Android now get it on your
iPhone I want to see that [ __ ] [ __ ]
babies um but yeah though that's the
whole deal with the [ __ ] robots
they're gonna [ __ ] us and we're done and
they don't get they don't guess why they
don't stop they stop when you know it's
not like they have an end game like when
we have sex we we were done when we have
an orgasm robots don't have an orgasm
robots are machines made for whatever
they're made for and then they just keep
[ __ ] you wanna get [ __ ] by robots
then you know keep it up
but whatever there's all sorts of new
problems that are well that will arise
and we just got to deal with the men
people are going to be out of work but
they're gonna be new jobs right you know
I'm not gonna be able to flip burgers
but but you know what your people are
going to be [ __ ] honestly I think
it's a good thing is what people are
going to be forced to do is [ __ ] do
jobs that humans should be doing that
that the people force people to be
[ __ ] it'll definitely for some people
to live their dream hey I'm getting out
of this burger flip and [ __ ] I'm gonna
[ __ ] be an artist and then somebody's
going to rise to fame and money because
of that is going to happen is it you
guess what
probably not cuz you could you probably
could um I don't know either way some of
you guys should be [ __ ] living your
dreams more but the some of you also
should not be hang it up if it hasn't
worked out in six years hang it up
so I'm going to check some
congratulations pot hashtags um so uh
here we go Oh somebody wrote you know a
lot about pro sports and athletes for a
guy who doesn't like sports you sports
fan
Sabrina Taylor at gangsta brunch oh wow
got a issue a fierce change it that's
the word that's actually the Wow I
actually honestly have never heard of a
[ __ ] worst worse worst worse handle
than gangsta brunch that's you should be
[ __ ] ashamed of yourself honestly you
should you should get off social media
gangsta brunch guess if it's a white
girl or not to love you Sabrina
but you driving me crazy with you stupid
handle thanks for listening I don't when
people are like you sure know a lot
about that are you sure that you don't
secretly nope you got to know a lot
about your enemy dude that's like one of
them [ __ ] you should know that you
sure know a lot about yeah I like what I
like watching [ __ ] that I hate though
isn't that are you [ __ ] crazy to not
watch it you hate I watch [ __ ] that's
bad all the time and people are like
turn it off and I'm like did you have to
watch a [ __ ] it's amazing infomercials
are my number one thing to watch they're
horrible dude I'll I know the
personalities I know the guy some guys
just are how about that there's just
guys that [ __ ] Hawk [ __ ] like
personalities that don't even give a
[ __ ] about the product and then they go
from product to product and say how
amazing it is you know they're lying you
know they're lying because that's their
job and they're talking about how
amazing a saw is who needs any of that
[ __ ] dude there's this one guy who is
just like this white guy that just looks
like the most regular [ __ ] and
he [ __ ] sells I actually took a video
of it the other day because it flipped
me out man
how do I [ __ ] videos this is the day
I did I did a 30-second mashup where he
says he's talked about this saw that
cuts at all that's what he's saying
it cuts at all I mean it doesn't though
you know what I mean like it doesn't it
straight-up doesn't cut it all it
doesn't it can't cut through cement and
this guy is just saying it cuts at all
and he's lying and we know it but but
people buy it that guy was on another
one that had wood they were selling
these christmas-light dude this was the
best it's always the laziest [ __ ]
[ __ ] - look how easy it is like what's
wrong with [ __ ] being kind of difficult
or just not even easy just regular you'd
be surprised you don't even have to lift
a finger this saw will get up on its own
and cut it all you don't even just tell
it I'll just [ __ ] give me salt do it
but these people this guy there's all
the one this Christmas lights one it
quickly is skyrocket my favorite
infomercial by the way is the old school
not the new one the old school now I
forget what it's called it's been so
long I think it's called total body with
with Chuck Norris and Christie Brinkley
Chuck Norris just didn't give a [ __ ]
about this product and you couldn't see
it behind his face and it was the best
but um total body I think total Jim
something I don't know but um this guy
this one made my was numb became my
favorite this guy who was this guy who
was doing the cuts at all saw whatever
it is had this other one that comes
around Christmastime and it sells he's
trying to hawk this [ __ ] product
where you don't have to put up Christmas
lights anymore you just set up like a
light show like a light [ __ ] jet I
don't know what you'd even call it like
it's like a spotlight thing but it's not
a spotlight but it projects a projector
that's what it is you put it in your
front lawn and it faces your house and
it it makes it it shows like a bunch of
like dotted green or red or [ __ ]
whatever color lights on your house like
it projects lights on your house that
it's supposed to look like Christmas
lights and it it doesn't it looks
horrible and this guy's like you don't
need to spend hundreds of dollars
getting a guy come out to put on [ __ ]
lights on your house or you're tired of
doing it yourself just get this
piss-poor projector and put it on your
front lawn look how amazing it looks and
it doesn't look amazing it straight-up
looks atrocious it's like when pigs are
swimming and you got to listen to
[ __ ] blink-182 not knocking 182 they
have some bangers and I'm not knocking
ja Rule but I'm just saying dude okay
dude I mean come on man it's just the
way he's talking to you get all hyped on
it you're like oh [ __ ] I gotta get that
look the way he loves it he's a [ __ ]
regular guy like my dad he's me I gotta
get that [ __ ] it cuts at all it cuts at
all dude let me ask you a question if
you're watching this [ __ ] thing what
the [ __ ] do you have to cut if you're
somebody that needs to cut [ __ ] like
honestly like saw wise you're not you're
not the kind of person that needs to buy
a [ __ ] saw
because in infomercials that you already
know all the sauce [ __ ] if you're
somebody that uses sauce you know about
sauce [ __ ] so if your is is for [ __ ]
plebeians you know what they're for
[ __ ] these therefore these Cudas dude
these kudos are watching TV need that it
cuts at all
I need that cousin CUDA Echota
did you buy anything on an infomercial
ever you khuda do these [ __ ] shiny
new things man you don't need it you
don't need it still raining in Toronto
actually it led up a little bit maybe I
can go out I don't have to wear all my
[ __ ] layers lonely out here man like
be in a big city you can get lonely dude
you really can you can get lonely in a
big city people say la is lonely it's as
lonely as you make it
oh I dry drag this [ __ ] Twitter
account I guess called [ __ ] deep
snaps first of all how confusing is this
[ __ ] deep first of all deep snaps
emotional snapchats pictures of [ __ ]
somebody in silhouette and then it says
something like never thought I'd lose
you but found the new me or some [ __ ] if
anyone ever sent me a [ __ ] emotional
snapshot I would delete snapchat drive
over to their head the house and pummel
this [ __ ] out of them then they post it
sometimes your best friend's best you in
a fight found the new me just dude don't
do a deep snapchat snapchats for dicks
it's for [ __ ]
you bits and pieces it's for you bits
and pieces information and funny things
that's it snarfer it's not for deep
emotional stuff hey I got a question
is it your phone is it an app or is it
your therapist oh dude does your phone
sit on a couch across from you and ask
you about your feelings do you pay your
phone two hundred and twenty dollars a
session nah because it's a phone not
your therapist so don't [ __ ] put deep
snaps and then it's on Twitter and then
they made an Instagram page about it hey
we're on Instagram on Twitter they told
us about their deep snaps hey we're on
Instagram on Twitter they said this this
is the [ __ ] inception its inception
so many social media outlets for deeps
for something that doesn't matter at all
that shouldn't be deep snaps no hey
watch my deep snaps on Instagram let me
tell you about it on Twitter what oh
it's confusing oh cool it's confusing
dude just be better and [ __ ]
follow it though who's worse that's what
I want too I think the worst is the guy
who does it not the follower because
there's always going to be [ __ ] [ __ ]
pieces of shits you know but just don't
exacerbate it don't capitalize on [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] be better be better that's
a deep a deeper a snap that I would do
but I put that on I can't tell if this
MattyB raps go go Twitter go on Twitter
look at MattyB raps ma TTY be are APs
he's 14 and he's tweet stuff like hide
your girlfriend I'm headed out for the
day and then a picture of himself I
don't I can't tell if it's I honestly
this guy maybe I don't think I don't
think he's choking
hide your girlfriend I'm handing out for
the day well like what like she's gonna
see him and is he a rat he's a rapper I
guess dialing up the haters he writes
and then pretends like his shoe is a
phone I guess is shoe I guess it's a
good shoe maybe I don't know dialing up
the haters and then and then it's
hilarious so he'll do that and then he
writes one went to the park with my
friends after school to make some funny
videos and then a just a picture of him
you're a tree-like bro
pick a lane you too kid or you Ludacris
if you Ludacris be ludicrous but if you
cute kid be dead I don't know man
oh man I love it I just [ __ ] it's
just I love
I just love and honestly I can't get
enough of because there's a lot of
[ __ ] idiots on and when I see it I
laugh because of you gotta watch it he
does the most submit point when he says
it to Twitter and he points it and then
he looks off into the sunset I didn't
realize that that's amazing um Wow
uh uh I'm gonna take one more question
and then I'm gonna [ __ ] head out and
because I got a lot of boring to be here
we go how do you go about math Matthew
at and his thing is at peckmon
underscore leg week change it what's up
dude why can't people have normal [ __ ]
alright how do you go about putting
material together for a special alright
let's get serious for a second what I do
is I start out with something that I
think is funny and I go on stage and I
start talking about it I have a part
that I think will make people laugh and
I'll talk about I'll talk as much [ __ ]
on the subject until I get until it's
not you know hidden and then I'll just
go to the part that I know is going to
make people laugh and then that'll
become the idea that I like or I don't
like and then I'll throw it out if I
don't like it I will start it again but
if I like it then I'll start to realize
what I'm trying to say and then as I'm
trying then then that'll become like
I'll do more material that's based on
that material like I'll do if I'm
talking about like the you know whatever
war whatever it is which I don't talk
about war but if I were to talk about
war then I'd start to talk and making
jokes about war and then I think about
why what is it about war and then I'll
start talking about other things that
are war like and then I'll turn it to
anything else anything else so just make
analogies to talk about [ __ ] you know
working out or something and and then
I'll well it'll just become a larger
point and then everything I talk about
will be will will be very very loosely
based on that point and I will basically
talk about different things and all try
to pretend it to that one thing in my in
my hour and that's specifically what
this last hour is definitely about it's
about me not wanting to pretend anymore
and me being the the me that I finally
realize it's okay to be and you know
it's a very general thing and then how
people react to that and now I am I am
that and now other people are that or
not that and then how it all you know
and so it becomes a little easier when
you feel when you real when you find
your the theme of what you're talking
about you know what I'm saying so that's
what I do leg week and right now I
fifteen new minutes that I'm doing since
I shot the special and that's kind of
becoming what I'm talking about now and
it's different than the last special so
that's what's up my special is coming
out this summer on Netflix called man on
fire man on fire and excited about it
it'll be this summer so that's that's it
I got real with you for a second but
this so that's it that's a that's it I'm
done with this podcast you guys thanks
for listening you guys are [ __ ]
awesome
and don't forget to download that square
cash app if you got an app that
transfers money delete it and do the
[ __ ] new one get this Square cash out
because it's better uh it's the best one
and you need to pay your [ __ ] goons
with it okay um do now do now but rate
and review this podcast it's uh I like
doing it when I'm doing it but it is
work and if the numbers don't go up I'm
gonna stop doing it okay uh I need them
try to back up this mother [ __ ]
Brinks truck to it so so help me out and
rate and review it and tell your friends
about it don't not do it do it and also
when you do it don't say I told you to
do it some people treat it like Chris
told me to do it so I'm doing this it's
not going to get people to watch so I
can get people listen um anyway
uh check out my tour dates chris d'elia
calm i rescheduled my arizona one i
rescheduled my West Palm Beach one and I
am coming to I am going to reschedule my
my australian one don't you worry it
will probably be somewhat later in the
year I hope so I really won't really
want to get out there so but go to my
Chris D'Elia go to Chris D'Elia calm and
find out or I think Chris Lee calm slash
tour either one works and go to look at
my tour dates and that's that and also
use the hashtag congratulations pod to
ask me questions and try and gain the
system all day long all right my babies
thanks for listening I love some of you
you know probably maybe some of you
listen I probably have a love for you
you know what I'm saying I'm Chris
D'Elia thanks for listening